[Music]
straight ahead on Long crime daily
a tense courtroom moment when defendant
Alex Jones has an outburst while on the
stand I don't apologize for it and don't
apologize Mr Jones please don't
apologize now I've already apologized to
the parents over and over again
don't apologize to you and outside the
courtroom Jones speaks to the media
about his testimony am I afraid of
statements I say here May
inside no I'm telling the truth here
plus we will not tolerate the gun
violence in this city
and we ask the community to be patient
and support us officials give an
impassion plea to the Baton Rouge
community of Louisiana following the
murder of LSU student Allison rice and
later after a jury rules in favor of his
accuser comedian Bill Cosby says he has
a right to a new trial law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to Long crime daily I'm
your host Brian buckmeyer right-winged
radio host Alex Jones gives explosive
testimony as he butts heads with a
plaintiff's attorney in the Sandy Hook
defamation trial last month the Texas
jury ordered Jones to pay 49.3 million
dollars in damages to the parents of
Jesse Lewis a student who was shot and
killed in the 2012 Massacre Jones now
faces trial in Connecticut as 15 planes
has filed a total of three lawsuits
against him after he claimed that the
school shooting was a hoax put on by
crisis actors the plaintiff is made up
of family members of the students killed
and an FBI agent say Jones's followers
have harassed them and even made death
threats Jones has already been found
liable for damages in this case meaning
jurors will now decide how much Jones
should pay as part of the plaintiff's
case Jones was called to the stand on
Thursday things got heated when Jones
told plaintiff's attorney Chris Maddy
that he was done apologizing this after
Manny suggested Jones put Targets on the
backs of Sandy Hook parents
she said that she loved me and I gave
her a kiss and I was out the door
that's Robbie Parker
that's the real Rocky Parker isn't it
I mean I said years ago I thought she's
gonna go ahead Robert Parker's sitting
right here he's real isn't he yes
and for years you put a Target on his
back didn't you objection to the form of
that judge oh well I mean
I've said his name it's true they are
you put a Target on his back just like
he did every single parent and loved one
sitting here no I didn't no you didn't
that's argumentative there's no
speculative there is no foundation for
it and it's inappropriate these are real
people
just like all the Iraqis but you
liberals kill and love
it's just you're unbelievable
you switch on emotions on and off and
you want you're it's just ambulance
Jason
why don't you show a little respect
objection I think that you get what you
give it is for objection
you have families in this courtroom here
that lost children Sisters Wives
moms
this is a struggle session are we in
China
I've already said I'm sorry hundreds of
times and I'm done saying I'm sorry I
didn't regenerate this I wasn't the
first person to say it American
Governors didn't like being blamed for
this as the left kid so we rejected it
mentally and said it must not be true
but I legitimately thought it might have
been staged and I stand by that I don't
apologize for it and don't apologize Mr
Jones please don't apologize now I've
already apologized to the parents over
and over again
don't apologize to you you're gonna do
it again
objection argument I apologize
well it's hard for me to get a word in
it twice it is
you're right I'm sorry I'm trying
to us today is legal analyst Dino Dahl
and co-host Terry Austin Dina I don't
necessarily respect and I actually I
don't respect it at all but I understand
why Jones feels he's done apologizing
but is that the smartest move to make
when a jury's deciding how much he'll
have to pay to these families
no I mean an apology or if you're sorry
isn't an element of the law here right
but he's already about been found liable
as you say and it goes to damages
compensatory damages how much do the
families actually lose as a result of
his lies that it's not going to be
relevant but there's a punitive issue
here and this is what makes the case the
most interesting because the punitive
under the Connecticut unfair Trade
Practices Act is not capped so they can
have a very high award here and one of
the things you look at when awarding
punitive damages is how malicious was
the act so his demeanor and his saying
there clearly he doesn't really care how
he affected the families that can tie in
to the maliciousness of how they think
the Acts were and may lead to a high
punitive reward no Terry was the
testimony on Direct truly helpful to
Alex Jones because he seems to think so
or did it hurt him
listen Brian if there was any testimony
that helped Alex Jones I did not hear it
first of all from a substantive
standpoint everything he said was
offensive he talked about liberals in
Iraq and China and I do think that
obviously all of that is irrelevant but
it's also inflammatory and it could
offend the parents and it could offend
that jury which is something he should
be concerned about and furthermore Brian
his attitude it's disrespectful it's
condescending he continues to ignore the
judge the judge has asked him over and
over to wait for her ruling when there's
an objection and he refuses to do that
we'll see how this plays out we've got a
little bit more coming up though still
ahead on lawn crime daily our coverage
continues of the Alex Jones defamation
trial out of Connecticut Jones discusses
his testimony with reporters outside the
courtroom why he says there was no need
for him to cross-examine
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we're taking another look
at the Alex Jones deformation trial out
of Connecticut on Friday defense
attorney Norman pattis waived his right
to cross-examine Alex Jones saying he
would call Jones the stand again later
after this Jones spoke with the media
outside the courthouse about the
decision and his argument with attorney
Chris Maddie
again more passes words Chris Maddie
crap the bed and uh his legal colleague
colleagues all over the state including
Democrats and Republicans uh judges you
name it have chimed in and said my God
that was the most disgusting thing
they've probably ever seen they looked
like a fool uh and then in case they
thought they were sure to win he may
have lost the case for him and I can
tell you Maddie's father is a famous
lawyer shoot him out and screamed at him
in there yesterday after we did I mean
he absolutely got completely out of
control trying to piss me off he got out
of control I didn't get out of control
and so we're just gonna let him throw
more fits in there and then he'll get up
there and Josh costoff will start crying
and then look at your end go cry cry and
try to get a big cry fest going in there
because they want to suck money out of
people the good news is I don't have
hardly any money despite what they lie
about in the press okay
there's as we see it there while Jones
is on the stand at the beginning and now
we see him outside speaking to the
courthouse uh the attorney Maddie argued
that what Jones says outside the court
has effects on the case so could
interviews like this hurt Jones in his
trial
oh I definitely think it could hurt
Jones listen this press conference just
like all of the others are really having
an impact on the case every single time
Jones holds a press conference we hear
the plaintiff's attorney confront him
now I will agree with Alan Jones that it
really was fireworks I don't think if I
had been the plaintiff's attorney I
would have attacked that hard but I
would ask about the remarks outside of
the courtroom and one of the things
storm Pat is should be telling Alex
Jones don't speak to the Press they can
have those words used against you and
most of the time you don't see clients
do that the general principle is you try
your case inside the courtroom and you
don't discuss it outside the courtroom
so I do think it's hurting him I do
think that it's right and fair game to
be asked about what he's saying outside
because he's saying some you know really
outrageous things about the judge about
the case about the system so I I think
he should listen to his attorney or
listen to other advice and not have
these press conferences do you know was
it a smart move for Jones's lawyers to
not cross-examine him on Friday and
maybe call him back on Direct another
time when things are less heated
you know I agree with Jerry there's like
two different courtrooms going on here
right the public which he's very eager
to talk to and then inside the courtroom
if you were a typical client I would say
their strategy was to do exactly as you
said take a breather you know let him
cool down let them restrategize let him
come back on Monday but I actually think
here we know that he is showing clips of
the uh courtroom and calling it a
kangaroo court on his show he's
basically making money on this show of
how he feels he's being harmed so I
think he may have wanted to delay things
because then he has the whole weekend to
fundraise off of it he has a whole
another day in the public to fundraise
off of it so you know I think there is
yes a legal strategy going on but this
might also be you know this is part of
what he does and it's a business move as
well absolutely and heading to Ohio
where jurors here once again from the
forensic pathologist who performed the
victim's autopsies in the trial of
George Wagner IV George along with his
brother Jacob and their parents Angela
and Billy are all accused of having a
part in the execution-style murders of
the Rhoden and Gilly families back in
April of 2016. all eight victims were
found shot to death some in their beds
as they slept initially officers thought
the murderers could be drug related but
later determined the killings allegedly
stemmed from a custody dispute involving
a child Jake shared with Hannah Rhoden
jurors are hearing about the murders one
seen at a time
Thursday and Friday's testimony focused
on the trailer where Dana and her two
children Hannah May and Chris Rhoden Jr
were killed the former investigator who
processed the crime scene told jurors
once again that no items from the home
contained DNA of any of the defendants
the corner then took the stand
testifying in detail about The Gunshot
paths in Dana's head
can you tell us um where was
uh gunshot wound number one located
on the diagram number one is on the far
left it looks like it's on the right
forehead it's a little more on the side
of the forehead
doctor can you tell us
um what did you determine the distance
to be of that gunshot wound
uh that is uh intermediate
okay and why did you make that
determination
um very faintly on the picture I think
there is a different picture there are
faint red
stippling marks from gunshot powder
striking her skin and were you able to
determine
um the path that that gunshot wound took
yes and what was that it traveled across
uh following a relatively straight path
to the left side of her head
uh struck the bone on the left side of
her head but did not exit and then fell
inside her skull to underneath her brain
coming up on lawn crime daily Bill
Cosby's defense team calls for a new
trial saying his accuser changed the
timeline of her story plus a Louisiana
State University student murdered in
Baton Rouge why investigators say
misinformation has been spread in the
death of Ali rice
foreign
[Music]
welcome back authorities in Baton Rouge
Louisiana are taking steps to ensure the
community's safety following the random
killing of LSU student Allison rice as a
memorial to the 21 year old grows
officials are investigating what led to
her murder rice was shot and killed in
the early morning hours last Friday in
her SUV while waiting at a railroad
crossing for a train to pass police say
she was driving home after a night out
with friends they say the shooter fired
into her car at least five or six times
hundreds attended the funeral which was
open to the public as rice was laid to
rest Wednesday a day later officials
addressed ongoing violence in the city
of Baton Rouge at a press conference
they talked about issues of
misinformation going around about the
Ali rice investigation including
dismissing rumors that the killing was
some kind of gang initiation police
chief Murphy Paul also answered
questions from reporters expressing a
heartfelt plea to the community
I know you guys are saying really tight
Lids about this alley rice case but what
can you tell the public like where are
you guys in the case like is this going
to be solved what's going on what I can
tell you is that our detectives are
exhausting every
investigatively
their their exhausting every
investigative effort
they're working hard we get three forms
promise you I will detectors are working
hard
what I ask this community to do is
please
lift the family up in prayer
to hear the heart of Christ
when you talk to me
the families and the family get hurting
good morning I'm asking you to be
respectful of that specifically
it seems that we have more questions
than answers so far does what we know so
far seem like it would lead to a suspect
or are we looking for the police to have
someone come forward and get more facts
you know what Brian this is going to be
a very difficult case I think both of
those things I think they're going to
talk to everyone and see if they can get
leads so they're asking people to come
forward but they're also going to have
to do that real legwork go out to the
scene look at those bullets what kind of
gun was it talk to every witness who saw
her prior to this event it really is
going to take a holistic approach
because right now that suspect is still
out there and they don't want to have
that continue for long they're looking
to make sure that that Community is safe
and so hopefully they'll ultimately get
something maybe even a reward would help
absolutely I think there may be an award
out there for more information Dina I
know the police don't want us to
speculate or give too much information
in terms of the investigation but
where's the balance to keep the public
informed the family's privacy protected
and seek Justice
I think that this kind of a case is
going to get a lot of public interest
it's random it was a young girl really
not obvious as to the motive and so if
the police feel that there's too much
misinformation out there they need to
give more press conferences they need to
give out more information because the
public really has a right to know what's
going on here and I think the mayor's
statement also kind of confused people
because she said that the same group of
people are committing violence again and
again and I think that's kind of where
that theory of gang violence may have
come from so maybe also coordinating
among themselves what kind of
information statements they want to put
out absolutely and police in North
Carolina released dramatic surveillance
video from an armed robbery at a fast
food restaurant take a look
this video posted to the Gastonia Police
Department Facebook page shows the armed
suspect pointing a gun at several
employees during the robbery at the
Bojangles fast food restaurant you can
see the suspect following the employees
into a back room area where police say
the suspect threatened the employees and
demanded they open the safe please
please say the suspect stole an
undisclosed amount of cash officials
also released footage of the getaway
vehicle which they described as a
light-colored minivan it is unclear if
anyone was hurt in the robbery
when we come back could Bill Cosby be
headed back to the courtroom why
attorneys for the disgrace committee and
say he deserves a new trial after jurors
ruled in favor of a sexual assault
accuser
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial will soon enter its next phase the
state's rebuttal following the defense
as suddenly resting its case early on
Tuesday the trial's focus will shift
back to the crime itself to what
happened on February 14th of 2018 when
an 19 year old gunman entered Marjory
Stoneman Douglas high school and killed
17 students and staff and injured 17
others it is a jury's job now to
determine if the shooter will be given
life in prison or the death penalty in
its rebuttal the state will answer to
the points brought up throughout the
defense's case that will include their
expert testimony attempting to minimize
expert testimony from the defense as
Witnesses once the rebuttal case is
finished the case will move in onto
closing arguments which are set for
October 10th
switching Coast now as disgrace comedian
Bill Causey says he deserves a new trial
months after a California jury found him
liable in a sexual assault case from the
1970s
now in her 60s accuser Judy Huff claims
Cosby sexually assaulted her at the
Playboy Mansion when she was 16 years
old in June a jury awarded 500 thousand
dollars in Damages in relation to the
case of civil suit was the first against
Cosby to make it to trial it came just
one year after Cosby was released from
prison when his criminal conviction for
the sexual assault of a different woman
was overturned now cause his attorney
says he deserves a new trial arguing
that he wasn't given the chance to
interview witnesses that could
corroborate his defense Cosby teams also
assessed Huff's changing story could
warrant a new trial they say she first
said the sexual assault happened in 1974
but later changed her story saying it
really happened in 1975.
Tina whether it happened in 1974 or 1975
either way it's nearly 50 years ago
could have mixed up like that really
warrant a new trial
no the standard for a new trial is
pretty high I mean he could I think he's
going to lose this motion he could still
bring these motions on a motion to
appeal and maybe more successful there
but the thing is is he actually tried to
attack The credibility of the uh
plaintiff with the differing years so he
also benefited from her changing the
story and then him not liking the other
um person talking about a similar
accusation he's saying that's propensity
which is not allowed the judge clearly
saying it goes to intent I think he
loses this motion yeah the jury got to
consider it it goes to the weight not
the admissibility type of argument Terry
at this point why would Cosby want a new
Civil Trial what could he have to gain
listen he is trying very hard to get his
reputation back remember as you said in
the lead up to this he was America's dad
there's no question about it in The
Cosby Show he portrayed a you know
wealthy family who was raising his
children with his wife who was a doctor
and then even before that he was a
comedian and he was known as being a
comedian who was clean cut and funny so
he definitely wants his reputation back
and now that he is out of jail for that
criminal conviction as far as Andrew
constan was concerned he wants to get
back his reputation on the Civil side
too it might be difficult to do whether
or not he wins the civil case but we'll
keep eyes on it Dina Terry thank you
very much and thank you for joining us
here on Law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]